you know all my friends were they were
taking stuff that would be intrinsically
interesting you know like animals like
and I was my mindset back then was how
easy is that you know to to to
photograph something that everybody
wants to see the trick to me was like
how do you take something that nobody
wants to look at and do the reverse of
it make it interesting because they need
to you know we need to look at it and it
just changed the mindset now of course I
know there's a there's a huge amount of
talent and research that goes into
making anything looks look amazing but
back then like you know I wasn't trying
to do stories on Paris or you know these
you know beautiful places on the planet
I was looking at you know the worst
places and try to make it look
interesting or try to you know find
something in it that was that made us
think about ourselves